this is what we've been waiting for
things are getting insane with betrayals
backstories and finally we actually get
Luffy versus kizaru and Zoro again
someone big too so make sure to stay
tuned for this insane chapter now
channel parking with it and smash that
like button if you enjoyed these one
piece reviews I want to keep them coming
make this the video you joined the
nakama by subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell if you haven't already
so you don't miss future one piece
videos and updates one more thing
hashtag one piece live action hype let
me know in the comments if you're just
as hyped as I am for it to come out very
soon and now without further Ado let's
jump into It spoilers and all so this
chapter 1091 is called sento Maru we get
a color spread of the crew eating pizza
and you can bet this is gonna be me
tomorrow when the one piece live action
adaptation comes out I also love how
classy these flamingos are so the
chapter itself starts with the
pacifistas and vagapunk Sea Beast
weapons attacking the Marines obvious
busy degrees by in the world is going to
have some good defense systems and Sea
Beast weapons for the win because
submarine battleships are actually sunk
by them it's actually crazy to see how
CB swap again just a bite a ship and
destroy it but of course the Marines
also knew this wouldn't be a walk in the
park and they came ready and with
strength and numbers we see two Vice
Admirals battling sea beasts doll kicks
a pacifista in the face and it
definitely looks like it heard the
pacifista while the vice admiral that
looks like a dinosaur with multiple
chins uses a mechanical arm to punch one
of the Sea Beast weapons and man I gotta
hand to him that punch really looks to
get hurt the Sea Beast weapon that is a
feat in and of itself I can only imagine
what that would feel like if it hit a
human but although it's interesting to
see more from these guys and to learn
more about their abilities we all know
the hype is mostly circulating around
kizuru and Saturn on the Marine side and
we jump to Kizer next we pick up what
Kizer and Central model where we left
off and as we already saw the two have
history kisado kicks and tomato and set
tomorrow's body flies away because of
the attack now I don't think anyone
expects septomato to send a chance
against kizuru in the long run and as
mentioned it's no surprise Luffy will
eventually come to the rescue but Oda
wants to show sentimaru's effort and
their shared backstory too in my view
Kiser doesn't necessarily like having to
fight him he even asks him why is he
siding with a pirate and sent omaru
replies an epic and Admiral fashion I
will join with anyone to save Uncle Punk
gotta respect that loyalty especially
when contrasted with a figure like kizu
kizuru for a while has been portrayed as
the Admiral who just goes with the flow
and follows the orders given to him but
I think we might finally be seeing some
tension and maybe he'll actually grow as
a character sooner at least we'll fully
learn why he is the way he is and why he
wants to continue being like that we
then get central models flashback and
it's the same story that Oda explained
in the volume 106 SBS the Marines
received a report report saying wild
bears are attacking human villages on a
certain Island and begapunk accompanied
them to set up a system to fight the
Bears when the Marines were
investigating the dangerous mountain
they came across a boy who defeated all
the Bears with sumo and he reigned as
the boss of the mountain if that isn't
badass I don't know what is being able
to fight Bears is always associated with
badass characters in anime just think of
takamura from Hajime and oipo so anyways
of course this boy is santomaru and it
definitely Hypes him up even more though
we all know he won't take down kizalu he
was a boy who was abandoned by the
villagers due to his violent behaviors
when he was younger intrigued by the
strength of that boy who didn't return
to the village and is always hungry Vega
Punk hired him as a bodyguard another
impressive thing when you see the panel
is how small sentimaru was he was
actually smarter than vegapunk at this
point and still taking down Bears we
find out that Kizer was the one who
accompanied vegapunk to help the
villagers and they both met santomaru
there it's interesting how Kizer history
goes even further back and yet Santa
Maru is still the loyal one defending
vegapunk while kizuru is the one trying
to take down vegapunk and Nelson tomaru
despite their history it's also fun to
see old Kizer with different clothing in
his hat he didn't even have any facial
hair which is crazy to see so as
mentioned vegapunk hired satomaru as his
bodyguard and santomaru asked kizalu to
teach him how to fight and become a good
bodyguard so we got a bit of a GARP
versus aokiji situation except the
teacher is the Admiral interesting how
Oda chose to put these two Mentor versus
student conflicts so close together but
it definitely flushes out the Admirals
which is really nice in the present
fight after kisuru kicks santomaru he
uses yasakani no magatama AKA yasakani
string of jewels in the anime it's like
when he makes it rain those dangerous
pieces of light and you can tell that
sento model is not in a good position
running sweating looking worried but
still this doesn't stop santomaru ponds
with ashigara dokoi AKA Sumo strike to
attack hisaru but it doesn't do any
significant damage to kizalu kizuru says
that he's taught satomaru as well as he
can but still his guard won't lose to
centumarus so it's a flex statement
where it's like yeah I taught you what
makes you strong but I'll always be
stronger and honestly it is cool to see
gizuru just take the attack and show
that he's fine after it rather than
trying to avoid it with his logia powers
and although he's a little talks big he
can definitely back this up and he
defeats santomaru with a strong beam
attack that creates a strong explosion I
don't think anyone expected this to end
differently but we gotta appreciate the
characterization for both of these
characters especially santomar then
kizaru does the Strategic thing of using
the command ship to command the
pacifistas to fight Vega Punk Sea Beast
weapons we get an important glimpse of
what is a conflicted kizaru in this
battle it's not like he doesn't care
about santomaru at all in their history
at all he says I just fulfill my mission
as if he's trying to justify himself but
he can't help but adding that he wished
he could have saved sentimaru along with
York punk records and power plant at one
point we see a close-up of gizuru's face
and again this is great storytelling by
Oda and character development right here
and subtle too he looks quite a bit more
serious and angry than usual I feel like
we'll keep getting kisuru development in
this Arc and I can't wait to see if he
comes to a snapping point and decides to
stop just following orders or why he's
so adamant about following orders we
then cut to outside the label phase and
we can see Vega Force One carrying the
sunny to the other side of the island at
the same time kizuru just flies through
the barrier man kizodo and his unique
powers are such a force to be reckoned
with that must be emphasized and
appreciated then comes something that
actually bothers me and we'll see if
it's explained better when the full
translate Pages come out but inside the
label phase Luchi attacks Vega Punk but
Stussy uses her body to protect him and
man we better not lose the attractive
Stussy here she was Loki a great Ally to
have on board right now and I want to
learn more about her powers I mentioned
before in previous chapters aloochie
wasn't in Chains and I wondered did he
even switched sides and I feel like if
there was any chance of this happening
like this betrayal happening which was
pretty obvious to see I think he should
have been in Chains I don't know why
they let down their guard and made
something like this possible I'm really
not a fan of how they already defeated
them then teamed up and now they're back
at it again to their old ways but at
least things go differently this time
Sanji uses the bubble gun to trap Kaku
inside of a bubble ball which is good to
see the last thing I need is to see Kaku
fighting again then Zoro attacks Luchi
and both of them go through the wall and
fly outside of the lap and honestly I
can't say this a better matchup than
Luchi versus Luffy at least I'd like to
see Luchi get beaten by Zorro so that he
knows he's now nowhere near Luffy's
level and I'm just always a fan of
seeing Zoro take on good opponents and
strong opponents so I'm excited to see
where this goes I guess from oldest
perspective he needed some good matchups
for the crew and if Luffy is going to
take on kizodu he probably needed Zoro
to take on someone significant too
although we still gotta see what's gonna
happen with the Elder that's the big
question right now then this last part
of chapter is so hyped kizuru is about
to follow Vega Force One and then Luffy
suddenly appears and kicks him and it's
an epic hockey infused kick Keizer
definitely doesn't just brush it aside
or ignore it now this is what we've been
waiting to see and what we've wanted for
so long like yes since we figured out
Kizer was coming but really we wanted
Luffy to take down an admiral for so
long Luffy says kizaru we are 100 times
stronger than two years ago he is
smiling as he's saying this and kizuru
is definitely not I'm telling you guys
one of these tractors kids are just
gonna snap and yeah that we are 100
times stronger than two years ago thing
is a great thing to say because it makes
us think about how overpowering his
little was before and how far our crew
has come since then and we'll be able to
see that clearly by how well Luffy alone
can do against gizuru this time oh man
I'm so excited but we are told there is
a break next week but hey live action
one piece definitely makes up for that
and then we get back to some gear 5
Luffy versus kizuru and I just can't
stop smiling as I think about all of
this awesome one piece content that
there's gonna be for us to enjoy great
time to be a one-piece fan for sure and
if you think he's just as hype as I do
then you don't want to miss our video
about all the Admirals in history and in
the present and their powers explained
link on screen right now like And
subscribe if you enjoyed the video and
I'll see you there